hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website calm today we're gonna be
looking at game number five from the
1971 Canada's tournament between
Petrosian who many thought would run
away with this tournament and his
competitor and that is bobby fischer up
into this point we are tied Bobby
Fischer won the first game Petrosian the
second game and we have had a draw since
then Bobby Fischer has the white pieces
going into game number five and starts
out with E for which he has done many
times over his lifetime he five a night
F 3 and then Knight to f6 so getting
into the Petra out the fence after the
night takes hear a d6 there's an entire
video you can watch on the Petrov
defense I've made if you're curious why
the knight does not come down here to e4
which would me and be a mistake
d6 the main line Knight comes back here
and then Knights going to take so both
sides have taken the e pawn from their
opponents most times and that's exactly
what Bobby Fischer does is he completely
avoids this Knight recognizing that it's
not gonna be doing too much right now
can't really threaten it unless he wants
to bring his bishop out here does not
want to stop his pawn so he continues
with pawn to d4 now the knight comes
back here the main line that you'll see
nowadays is d5 this is centralizing the
pot a little bit more and making this
outpost for the night here on e4 but
it's had to go and bring his knight back
to f6 and then Bishop to d3 preparing to
castle on the King side
Petrosian continues with Bishop to e7
getting ready to castle on the King side
himself and then we see h3 now it's
pretty common just to play Knight to c3
here this gets more material involved
into the game not sure if Bobby Fischer
I just been playing with Petrosian felt
like there was the bishop coming down
here to g4 wanted to stop that threat
but either way decide to play h3 more
defensive play but does make sure that
there doesn't come anything on the King
side of the board and then both sides
castle and then c6 another interesting
move as well instead of c6 there's
there's lots of options here you get
your Bishop involvement of the game
Bishop here to e6 you know the most
common here is Knight to c6 even if you
want to swing your rook over here to e8
yeah you probably
get your bishop out of this lock that it
has here on e7 at some point but rook to
e8 makes a lot of sense to place c6
blocking off your knight coming in to c6
definitely something that I wasn't
expecting to see as I was analyzing this
game rook t1 from Bobby Fischer
controlling that open e file in the
night to d7 so this does offer up for
the night to come to multiple squares
but it's probably not going to come to
the center of the board which makes it a
little surprising to me
c5 an e5 are both blocked off by this
pawn here on d4 so gonna be looking for
another option could definitely exchange
here if Bobby Fischer were to take but
no real need for him to do that right
now
besides first to bring his dark square
Bishop out here to F 4 and then rook to
e8 all those make a lot of sense
pawn pushing forward to c4 and then
Knight to f8 so it seems like this was
what Petrosian had planned all along get
the knight back here so he can bring it
to e6 if he wants to centralize it on
that front or g6 he does have some
options here but right now it is
definitely on the eighth-ranked not
doing as much as he is probably hoping
for right now c3 just getting his Knight
more involved into the game a 6 here
blocking off some of the squares on the
Queen side the Bobby Fischer could go to
Queen here to b3 a knight to e6 so
centralizing that Knight Bishop comes
back here to h2 it is under attack here
Bishop comes back to f8 opening up for
the rook to also control the open e file
both sides are basically doing the same
thing here Bobby Fischer since he has
completed development has all of his
pieces here can easily swing his rook to
e1 put double rooks here and have more
control over this efile pawn to b5
recognizing he can't really control the
e-file can't really control the kingside
decided to start pushing on the Queen
side of the board rook to e1 says he I
don't really care about the pawns over
here right now
Bishop to b7 and then Queen to c2 and
this is an interesting pot where I
thought Bobby Fischer could have tried
something differently you always want to
be
where your opponent is moving away from
this bishop here on c8 is protecting the
nights here on e6 as soon as it moves
it's no longer protecting that the pawn
and the rook are the only two pieces of
material defending this I think Bishop
to f5 makes a lot of sense you can't
really kick this bishop away with
something like a g6 you could just have
an exchange right here rook can come up
this is gonna be pretty good for for
white you can also see there's
completely decimated the pawn structure
in front of the King here but he doesn't
instead decides to play his Queen to c2
and then Petrosian not sure if he just
immediately saw this but then played g6
now you can see this is very different
the bishop can no longer come to F I put
a lot of pressure on this efile with his
bishop so I think Petrosian in this
spots got away with something we're
Bobby Fischer could have had a much
bigger advantage now Bobby Fischer plays
b4 trying to push on the Queen side as
well
pawn captures Bishop recaptures here on
c4 Knight swims back to c7 so I'm really
trying to figure out what he's gonna be
doing with this Knight it is moved all
over the board Bishop comes back to a b3
Bobby Fischer always liked to keep his
bishops back here on this long light
square diagonal whether if it was on a 2
or b3 here putting a lot of pressure on
his opponents King if it's castle on the
Kings side and there was no pawn here on
e6 just something if you analyze a lot
of his games he always liked to park his
bishop back here on the Queen side would
you see an exchange on the board
so right now Bobby Fischer does control
the e-file with his rook Knight comes
down to d5 and then upon to a3
controlling this pawn here on before
another interesting idea that he could
have played is Queen to be - this is a
fun way of defending the pawn because if
the knight war to take here on before
Bobby Fischer has the surprise move of
Bishop takes on f7 check after the King
takes then the Queen can take here on b4
so you always want to look at the
threats that you have with your Bishop
checking your opponent and then putting
the
behind that with discovered attacks is
always something to be thinking about
that's one of the good reasons that
Bobby Fischer has of always eyeing down
his opponents king with his Bishop but
instead decides to go ahead and play a
three just a little fine the pawn chain
after a five here we see the knight
capture we do see an exchange and then
the pawn coming up here to be five so
the Bobby Fischer cannot connect these
have a stronger pawn structure decide to
go ahead and play a four definitely
think that's the right move here both
sides have six pawns
Petrosian on one side though has double
pawns here in the middle now this is a
pawn by itself doesn't have any other
pawns to protect it so really Petrosian
if you look at it's gonna be looking to
attack this pawn anyway shape possible
and then as much as you can hold on to
these pawns no and it's gonna be pretty
difficult
going into the endgame here Bishop comes
back to a two Queen to b6 attacking the
pawn here Queen back here to b1
defending that and you start to see all
the material lying down on this B 5
square root to a5 attacking that rook
over here to a b2 attacking that Knight
to e4 and you may say well that doesn't
necessarily attack it right away
but it's definitely coming because after
Bishop to f4 the next move is Knight to
c3 so the Knights the rook and the Queen
all attacking that right now Bobby
Fischer recognizing can no longer hold
on to that pawn it's it's now time to
start looking at different options Queen
to c2 starting to eye this other pawn
here on a4 so after the rook takes on b5
rook takes Knight takes up here then the
Queen can take on a4 so yes we are still
equal in material Bobby Fischer has a
passed pawn on the a file and Petrosian
has double pawns on the D file so things
in this position definitely looking up
for Bobby Fischer but still has a pretty
active position that he has to worry
about from his opponents Queen to a6
decides to go ahead and exchange here
Bishop takes on a six and then Bishop to
e3 and this is important because it kind
of looks like there's a free pond to go
ahead and take here on the
five but after Bishop takes on d5 then
Petrosian can just play Knight to c3
this is not only attacking this Bishop
here on d5 it's also preparing for the
night to come down to e2 that would be a
fork King and the Bishop are under
attack this Bishop would fall so there's
no real good move for bobby fisher' he
could just try to get as much material
as he could Bishop takes on f7 there is
an exchange and then he could play king
h2 maybe has has some options here but
just trying to avoid Knight coming here
to e2 so while the pond does look like
he can be taken unfortunately that would
be a trap so he correctly sees that and
plays Bishop to e3
now the knight takes on a3 as soon as
the knight comes down here no longer
threatening coming to c3 does need to
stop at that pass pawn priority number
one for Petrosian and now Bobby Fischer
can easily recapture here on d5 both
sides equal in material gonna be
difficult for either side to win here
but Bishop to c4 attacking the bishop
bishop comes up c6 Bobby Fischer not
looking to exchange right now Knight to
see to starting to attack the bishop and
the pawn here says yeah I can go take my
pawn it's protected by my own pond then
Bishop comes down says I'm gonna attack
your knight here so then we see the
bishop come down attacking the Knights
you can just see how all of this is
complex all of the exchanges all of the
interactions going into the endgame if
there's one incorrect move this whole
thing falls apart luckily for both these
players they're extremely talented and
I'm making a lot of mistakes in this
game so Bishop takes Bishop comes down
takes here on c2 Bishop comes up to a d5
and in this spot they decide to draw the
game no real way for either side to get
an advantage so game number 5 Bobby
Fischer he came out the gates pretty
strong game 1 got the win maybe thought
that he was going to run over his
opponent remember coming up into this
his previous two opponents he had won
every single game one game one against
Petrosian since then he is not won a
game lost game number two and had three
draws
that too of which he has the white
pieces so he'll be looking to come back
in game number six with the black pieces
and see if he can make something happen
but on the other hand recognizing that
he really has the advantage right now
held off Bobby Fischer in Game five and
going into Game six he does have the
white pieces thank you guys so much for
watching Game five hopefully you're
enjoying the 1971 Canada's Tournament
always fun to watch and analyze some of
the old historic chess matches between
two of the greatest chess players that
we have to analyze games on but thank
you guys and I will see you again in
game number six